Ok, so we activated the electricity outside at the battery storage place and now we have
here different buttons.
When you push the black one down, then you see everything starts.
Ok, to start the engine, you see the big grey button.
Don't push the clutch or nothing.
You see, I thought it is no gear, when you put the clutch, it doesn't start.
Now you can see, here we have the pressure for the brakes.
One circuit is low.
Now we must wait, since the pressure is on 10 bar.
To make it faster.
10 bars, yeah?
Yeah, if not, the brakes doesn't loose.
So you can be sure when these red lights are shining, we can't drive.
So now we are here in the middle, here is the spring part for the throttle.
Now you can go a little bit up.
You can use the gas pedal.
You can use also the gas pedal, but it needs time to fill.
So when you do it with the throttle button, that is easier.
You need the gas pedal.
And the throttle is to the right, yeah?
Right is up.
Yeah, you can see, there is a plus and a minus.
So very easy.
Yeah.
And then you can see here, now the lever goes up.
See, now we are there over five.
Yeah.
And this time we need, before we can start.
That is one thing for now, every morning I thought, carry me to start the engine and
let it fill the brake system, because then it holds for the whole day, but no longer.
And we must fill it again every day.
Yeah.
So now we must wait.
Then, here is another button.
Here you must pull.
Handbrake.
This ring you can move.
Wait.
Okay.
And when it's up, you can put it forward and then you lose the brake.
Yes.
Now the handbrake is loose.
But we have not enough pressure, so the red lights are shining you, okay?
Not enough pressure, we can drive.
So we must wait.
Also what happens if one drives without the pressure being good?
You can't drive.
It doesn't work.
It's the engine dies.
So when you try to start, the brakes are closed.
So you can't drive.
Yep.
You see now the handbrake is loose.
You can see later when the pressure is okay, the lights go off and then the fire truck starts rolling.
Yeah.
Okay.
For himself, because we have no gear, but we are staying here not straight.
So then we have another thing that is later.
You have here a sign for the gears.
That is very easy.
It's also easy to work with.
Yep.
And all these buttons, all these four buttons are not for use.
That is only for special stations.
This is blocking the axles and everything and it's dangerous to use without knowledge.
Okay.
When you use this, it's only for hard terrain.
When you go up mountains or something or you are driving in mud.
Ah, yeah, yeah.
And so it's really important, don't touch these things.
No touch them.
If you work with these and start driving, you damage the whole gearbox.
And that is very expensive.
Okay.
Because when you want it for you to explain, when you put these locking parts in, it blocks
the parts inside the axle.
And then it's not allowed to use the steering.
Only drive straight.
Ah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
If not, you break something.
Otherwise one wheel is going to spin more than another one.
And then that's the reason it can destroy the axle.
Right, right, right, right.
Okay.
Now you see the lights are off.
Yeah.
If we want now, put the first gear.
ETHAN firefighters on the mission.
The important is put back the throttle on low level.
So you cannot throw other throttles just to kick it on into the bars.
Yeah.
And later for activating the pump and put the throttle that we can have enough pressure
to spray the water.
So similar to the tractor with the dropper basically.
Yeah.
Right foot.
Lower to the left.
Ah, the door.
The door is under the ease.
Ah, yeah, yeah.
I don't know.
Right, right, right.
What are you doing?
No, no, no, no.
Nothing touch without instruction please.
Okay.
This is one thing we never use because we have no alarms in here.
Oh, don't care about this.
This truck had worked in areas like that.
Wow.
Watch this to be careful with the trees.
Okay.
So it's made for off-terrain, yeah?
Yeah, for sure.
It's a permanent 4x4 ride.
Wow.
Now we go irrigating.
The rest we do in the afternoon.
Okay.
I'm just going to show you because you can drive directly.
Yes.
Okay.
Thank you.
See you later guys.
Thank you, Super Mike and Super João.
Well.
Pizza, pasta.
Mario Luigi.